hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
fully automated targeted snip genotyping
for plant and animal applications
i'm michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by beckman culture life
sciences
for more information on our sponsor
please visit
beckman.com now let's get started
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by clicking on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our speakers
jurgen zimmerman
the senior engineer of automation at the
genomics core facility
at embl and bjorn tech store
the senior application specialist at new
england
bio labs for a complete biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen you're going
to be orange you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much michelle for this
kind of introduction and welcome
everybody to today's webinar
first of all i would like to thank
beckman culture life sciences and lab
roots for organizing this event
and jave and i are very happy to give
you an introduction
about the nab next direct geotyping
solution
a novel technology for targeted
geotyping that we were using
in conjunction together with the biomac
i7 workstation from beckmann hooder
to generate a fully automated target
script genotyping
approach for plants and animal
applications
during the webinar we'll provide you
with several information
uh on the nbnex direct genotyping
solution and this
this is a very new technology we will
kind of we would like to introduce you
into how where does it fit how does it
work
and then also looking into manual data
how robust
is it and then finally bringing this
into the automation contact
content how this works on the biomach i7
workstation
let's get started how does it fit
what is it when we're looking
uh generally on to genotyping
application
this can span a huge variety of areas
from agricultural biology where you're
thinking about genotyping
genomic selection market assisted
breeding qtl mapping or
qc application all the way to
translational research where you can
envision it in
population screenings gvs or model
organism screening
market discovery downstream clinical
applications
where you're looking at polymorphic risk
scores diagnostics
clinical trials or sample tracking
at this point the neb next direct
geotapping solution
is developed for agriculture or animal
applications
assisting breeding and livestock
multiplication
when you think about all these different
applications we also
think about different options how to
perform the genotyping
so we tend to think about this in two
axis
on one of the axis on the horizontal one
we do have
the number of samples that we can
process through a given laboratory and
this is a function of complexity
of these workflows as well as the costs
that they are associated with
we think about the number of markers on
the other axis
we think about this relatively how many
genotyping we can perform
in parallel so in this figure we
attempted to place
those technologies into various buckets
to showcase where they fit
into the greater strategy things such as
summer sequencing
that might be good for relatively low
cupid processing in terms of number of
samples
and relatively low number of markers
will for example endpoint pcr
where we really look at slow numbers of
markers but can extend
that due to the low cost over tens of
thousands of samples
at the other end of this spectrum we do
have different sequencing technologies
as well as microarrays
where you can look at a very high number
of markers
to be genotypes but the cost of some of
these workflows
might make it a little bit difficult to
apply these technologies
to a very high number of samples
the middle of this we do have targeted
next generation sequencing which i think
occupies sort of a niche in terms of
being able to look at a
relatively high number of markers and by
reducing the cost of sequencing you can
actually apply this
to more samples in the various
considerations one might put into place
when you're determining which technology
the technology you can use
for different applications take account
uh various considerations such as sample
numbers and market numbers
you want to look at cost per data point
um
the current flexibility of the
technology so can you change anything
once your panel is designed scalability
also very interesting is the ability to
gain contextual genomic information
around your marker
and then finally also the ability to
besides um smps also detects
insertion and deletion
so with the navnex direct geopatent
solution
we really wanted to generate a child
enrichment ngos approach
to reduce the cost per essay by being
able to use more samples per sequencing
run
plus expanding the capability of trying
with ngs
out into the tenth of thousands of
hundred or thousand samples
when looking at the antibiotics direct
geotyping solution workflow from a high
level
you can discriminate between a minimum
number of samples that can be processed
up to a very high number of samples that
can be processed
to do so we are using the same protocol
but uh
using different strategies of pre-pool
plexi
as well as sample pool plexi to obtain
the different throughputs so in this
case here you see the minimal
input of samples into a process where
you are processing up to 96 samples
uh into a one library prep process
and this goes then into one sequencing
reaction
on an illumina sequencing instrument
which then generates
up to 96 datasets as a maximum for
throughput capabilities
we can use 24 or up to 24
384 well played and put all these
samples
into a 96 uh library preps
so into a single 96 well plate which
then goes
um consequently onto the sequencer and
generate
uh over 9200 data sets in one sequencing
run
the goal of the navy next direct
genotyping solution project
was to reduce cost and streamline
workflows
through pre-capture pooling of up to 96
samples
the video sequencing efficiencies would
do a barcoding sample indexing
plus unique molecular identifier
imprinting target coverage and
uniformity through unique capture based
arrangements
to animate marker uh dropouts from with
fine
tuned weight design and increasing
sample throughput
using a one day protocol which already
from development had automation in mind
and we go all to this detail
in a minute so how does the abnex direct
geotyping
solution works when we are looking at
the
direct geotyping solution workflow we
discriminate between two parts of the
workflow
the first part of the workflow is the
sample barcoding and the pooling
strategy
so at this step we are processing
each sample individually and then
putting this into a pool
with finally downstream um moving it
through denaturation hybridization for
target enrichment
so the region of interest and then
building a library
from the target enrichment step we are
talking about a pool
term sample or pool which contain
up to 96 samples in one pool
and how this works i will show you in a
minute
to really understand the bar coding
strategy of the genotypic solution i put
here
uh this slide what we um throughout the
process what we generate is the library
but on the one
on the one side we have a sample index
that tells you in which well
of the 96 well played the sample was
located
and then we have an additional
hybridization or as we call
pool index which tells you in which pool
or
in which 96 world plate the sample was
located
so in the combination of sample index
and hybridization slash pool index
we have a capacity of 9262 combination
which can go onto an illumina sequencer
when we're looking into the detail of
the workflow
it all starts with a genomic dna that is
isolated
from the crop or the species of interest
so the unsheared dna
goes first into an enzymatic based
fragmentation that also concludes with
end repair
fastband phosphorylation as well as
detailing
for the geotyping solution we need input
material
from 10 to 100 nanogram of dna for each
individual sample
and i would like to point out in terms
of plants
this can also vary determined by the
size
of the genome of the crop
after the fragmentation and repair
we are moving right away into the
ligation of the first
adapter we are locating here a five
prime
custom adapter that carries an eight
base pair
sample index as well as a 12 base per
unique molecular identifier once
all the samples are attacked with this
adapter
each individual sample carries a sample
index
which allows them then for subsequently
pooling of up to 96 samples
into one pool finally to reduce
the the the amount of volume that we
have in this pool
we are concentrating this pool down to
60 microliters
using magnetic beams at this point we
have a pool
and all steps downstream are then
processed not on a single individual
sample base
but on the pool that contains up to 96
samples
which allows to save costs in terms of
plastics
but also reduces dramatically hang on
time
once we generated the pool we are moving
then
directly into the target enrichment
process where we denaturate
and then hybridize the sample to balance
related base
the base are targeting both strands of
the dna and can target
up to 5000 markets per sample
the base are placed within 75 nucleotide
proximity
to the target of it to the market of
interest
the whole hybridization time for this
part of the workflow takes 90 minutes
after the hybridization of the base we
are
then removing by enzymatics by an
enzymatic step
the three prime of the throughput region
of the
of the bait to reduce off-target effects
and get more stringent sequences
at the end using magnetic strep dividend
b
um we are doing a couple of washi area
to get rid of all the
unwanted dna sequences
after removing of the three prime off
target region
and generating a blunt end we are then
adding the second adapter the three
prime adapter
and which then are subsequently followed
by a final pcr
where we are then building the file
library and integrating
the pool index on the on the one side of
the
of the library again with a combination
of the sample index
and the pool index we can pool up to
9216 samples
into a single sequencing run
just as a reminder here um the directed
general genotyping solution
or workflow contains a single uh
individual
um process step a sample step
and then a pool sample step and it's
really designed for automation
and also only takes one day to finish
the library
besides of all these uh we also
streamlined
the sequencing reaction
on the illumina sequencing platform so
to to get data out of this
we uh read read one where we have
20 cycles on the sequencer to read the
12 base per umi
as well as the eight base pairs sample
index followed by
uh read two where we have at least 75
bases
that is reading into the into the region
of interest
to identify the target um and this uh
adds all together to a number of 95
total cycles
for a single minus six uh pool of
samples
in addition if you have more than one
pool you
have the flexibility also to read in the
i7 index another eight
basis of the pool index that ends up
with a
total number of 103 cycles
to sequence a multiple 96
plex pool of samples all of this uh
leads to a 10 to 12 hour sequencing run
on the mysqq and also keep in mind that
the
web lab process to generate the
libraries takes approximately a day
you can you can get from samples to data
within 24 hours
how robust is the technology
as i said the anybody next direct
genotyping solution
can be applied to various applications
um as you can as you remember from the
beginning
there are plant applications animal
applications but also human applications
we started off with developing this
technology
with a partner here in europe to
to develop it for market assistance
selection and breeding
also quantitative trade local screening
and now expanding
also into animal and human applications
such as ngo sample tracking
today i said we will be focusing on the
plant applications
i really test the performance of the
technology
we generated three different types of
panels
for tomato maize and rice where we are
using publicly available
slip content from the from the socap
project for tomato but also from the
panzera project for mice
and the generation challenge program for
rice
to generate some data that are not of
property information so most of the
people using the
genotyping solution so far are working
with
custom panels that contain a hundred to
five thousand
proprietary snips and we are very happy
to discuss all the projects
together with you here we are now
presenting data
uh on the 2300 snip panel
from the um forecast project
what you can see here is a similar
sample
that shows you uh the uh coverage
uh of all the 2300 markers
that are in this vocab panel
and what you can see here is that we
generate a very nice uniform panel
and even distribution of free over these
different markers
this is something that we are very proud
of and achieved this by
by generating these dates
individually at neb for me we are
synthesizing individually
and then generating xc molar pool and
then
sequencing actually the the the panel
and then determining determining over
and under represented regions
so for the over-represented region we
are then
decreasing the concentration of the
molarity of the base
whereas for the under-represented
regions we are adding additional days
to have the best uniform coverage is
possible
so that you have not to spend too many
secrets in a week
to to monitor all your markets of
interest
interestingly we are also storing all
the dates
individually so that they are all there
also the ability
to change content very easily over time
rather than starting to produce a new
panel from scratch
looking then at how this performs over
the all the different samples
in this case here you do see 96 samples
and each sample contains
2 300 markers of the full cap tomato
panel
and what we show here that we are able
by the pooling strategy
to distribute uh equally well uh
the the filter to each sample which
contains between 250
000 and 300 thousand degrees
for capture efficiency again uh what you
see
here is again the nineties examples the
example again two thousand three minute
markers
and the specificity is not dropping
between the individual samples so each
sample
is working equally well and
really the goal to have more efficient
use of the sequencing data
finally when we're looking at the mean
target coverage also in this case we can
we see that we have a very nice even
distribution
over these 96 samples with each 2 300
individual markers
nice way to use the technology is
also to use it for different parts of
breeding processes so you could envision
that there are also
requirements that you are just using the
subtool of
the the main pool that you are working
with what you can see here
we were filling out a 500 marker panel
and a 96 marker panel
out of the 2 300 uh total market panel
and what the igv board shows you that
they have equal
coverage across the subset that enables
you also
to use a different subway but have
and provides you with flexibility
over these different market sets
so for the neb next there geotyping
solution has been used for
different types of crops um from
sunflowers to rapeseed
but also including some of the
ornamentals already
i just wanted to remind you if something
like this is interesting for you
um the requirements to generate such a
custom panel for you
is not much we only need a partial
reference genome or amplicon sequence
with at least a 75 nucleotide a phantom
region
um for other um species um
or even human coordinates of targets
could be used
and then we are using also we would
require a dna sample
of your origin so what we do is here is
we're really partnering together
to really have the design and the
production of these panels
according to your needs and also your
specific dna isolation
but once you reduce the pool you can
directly move forward with
the production and using the technology
with this i would like to end and i'm
happy to hand over to you
thank you bjorn first i like to give
credit to the people where i had a
pleasure to work together on this
automation project
so actually it's martin gina from
beckmann
and i'd like to think especially for his
endurance taking our feedback and
optimizing his
program and then michael petridis from
neb biolabs and his patients checking
what the machine is doing and his
valuable feedback for optimizing the
biochemical
protocols and susan from directed
genomics for her very fast response
her analysis and her general support
actually now i like to summarize just
the
goals we have with this automation
project
uh the first important thing for us is
always a full
walk-away automation and this has
several reasons
the first one we are core facility and
we like to
utilize the resources we have optimally
which means we like to operate during
the night
and utilize the machines as long as
possible
the other point of course is that if you
like to
wish to scale out for higher throughput
you need interfaces
and this makes only sense if there's no
human interference necessary if you are
thinking
of level feeders and if you like to go
to ultra high throughput with acoustic
dispensers or
anything like that you have to move out
of the machine
and there shouldn't be no need to go to
the system again
of course data quality should be at
least equivalent
to the manual processing and there we
took the benchmark
from nab and from the lab people there
then of course we are actually targeting
on process stability
so which means we need in-plate
homogeneity
of results and play-to-plate results
shouldn't vary
system robustness is very crucial
because
if you are testing it only in a defined
lab in the
environment then most of the systems and
protocols are confronted with real life
which means tolerating variability and
tolerances in plastic materials
and also the input material which means
the dna material is it's not always
stable so
protocols may vary actually the
development status of the plants may
vary a little bit
and so you have to cope with these
situations
the other point is we developed a
prototype in a way
so actually we are looking already for
our scalability which means from a small
number
of samples we like to go already to a
higher sample set
so actually already by software we allow
a great flexibility from this mid-range
processing capabilities to high
throughput
capabilities i go to this point a little
bit later again
and make reference all the time where we
see the potential and actually where we
have
integrate already the options which
makes it possible
to increase throughput then cost
effectiveness
is very crucial if if you may consider
that you are going to throughput or
ultra high throughput
then each cent or fraction of ascent is
counting
at the end to your final bill and this
is related to plastics
all different kinds of plastics and of
course the biochemical consumption which
means
the stuff you are using during pipetting
the dead volumes and your reservoirs for
example
last but not least it's about sample
tracking
because you shouldn't lose overview
about the samples you're processing
and as the system is bringing already
some capabilities
with it it's quite supportive in the
development process and then later on
operations at first i like
to have a short glimpse on on the
process
itself so here it's already
scaled for biomec i7 with
96 well hat so if you look at the
process
you can divide it in two parts in the
beginning
you are still dealing with individual
samples
and at a certain stage you start pooling
it
and then you're only operating with
pools of 96 for example
and the time
we have put below so it is 480 minutes
for a complete set of 996 is real time
most of the times are following really
to the incubation times which are
mentioned in the protocol
and sometime for pipetting as we are
optimizing the whole protocol
it's not scaling too much which
increasing throughput
the only thing which is definitely
scaling at that point
if we are pooling because then we have
to operate
with single tip operation and there
we're just running in the limit
so there is no potential to scale up
further at that point
if you like to scale up just from this
single 96
well operation it's quite
straightforward with the basic system
which i will introduce later just by
multiplying or repeating
the first part of this single sample
processing four times
and then continuing just with the number
of pools
but there's a more easy way for doing
this i'm coming to that point later
now i'd like to show you the i7 actually
we decided to go with the i7 and this
has
several reasons first is okay we had
some experience with biomec fxp
and were quite satisfied but the whole
design
offered some capabilities which actually
really makes it a very good option for
this process
first point as we have two arms which
can
handle which can be configured in two
different options so we
went for a span8 configuration on one
and the 96 well hand on on the other arm
so for hit picking master mix
distribution
which we are doing during the incubation
time so we are not losing
any any times and 96 well here just
processing samples in parallel
now it's also the very favorite option
we can switch between 96 100 and 384
wall head so if you're considering
scaling out
you just can switch ahead and put a 384
overhead and then you are multiplying
just by factor of four
you may also adjust another component on
the system i will
show you later so the other point is
which is quite neat with this
instrument are these two independent
grippers mounting
on these two arms so at the end this
combination of
two heads which can move independently
and two grippers which can move
independently
allows a certain type of multitasking so
the system
is doing on its own already on some
scheduling
and try to intercept and also to
move different processes and subparts
into each other
and optimize the whole throughput up to
a certain extent
the whole system also offers in our
configuration
an integrated pcr system so
no samples have to move to be moved out
of the
at all during the processing time
multiple cpac
components of t elements allow the
storage of master mixes at 4 degrees
and the samples at 40 degrees are
actually pre-incubation steps
what i like to mention here is a system
which is called dart
and actually i just like to introduce it
a little bit because i don't know
whether we have
too much time for questions at the end
dart is a system which is embedded into
the
biomag operation system which allows
tracking of samples
so at the point when the sample plate or
set of samples is introduced to the
system
you can query it via sql statement
from your lymph system or you can query
it from
an excel sheet or what whatsoever and
then you can bind this data type for the
individual samples together with a plate
id
which is preferably coming from a
barcode reader which we have also built
in on
on the system and from that time on the
sample information is bound to display
during the whole process until the end
when it starts in the cool pcr position
that it can be stored overnight the
advantage of this is not only that
this is it allowing tracking during the
whole process
but you can bound additional information
to it which means
quality values at the end and with the
plate id it's very clear that the next
process is already predefined
so as an example as we have produced
already a library during the process and
somebody placed this plate again
on the machine the biomec would be quite
reluctant to
proceed is further on because it's very
clear the system knows it's already
pre-processed so
please don't select this protocol again
so it's a very
potential system which is integrated
so the last but not least option is we
have implemented already
several nab protocols on the system
and we know about the performance so
several dna protocols
uh the whole portfolio of rna protocols
from
nab is running and it's capable to
process
single cell applications which is quite
important to us
and it's not wrongly running any b
protocols but we can run smart zig and
other ones so you get the
information out of it so let's come to
the basic
deck layout how the system looks like
embl
so there are these passive positions
which are here in gray
which are named pls or p
positions which are passive which means
you can place
plates on it tips on it that's it
then we have a position which is called
tr2 this is just a waste container
together
for stuff which is used on the system
and then we have active positions which
is an
orbital shaker which we need for beat
purification
which are actually easied up for mixing
then we have several pk positions as i
mentioned before in our case it's three
then we have an active wasp wash station
to prevent tip exchange
at each step and then we have positions
which are called
lf lf and tr1 i just lab their feeder
and now we are coming to another option
to scale it up
this lf positions allows the storage of
more than
15 tick boxes in a cassette
and more than 20 microtiter plates of
different types
so in principle we are also able to feed
up additional
disposable material plastics from the
side together
with the extension of of the head we
will gain then
another level of throughput on that
system
but coming back to this basic
configuration i'd like to show you
here we see on the right side we see
tips which are exclusively for the span8
component
then we have a cool position for the
master mixes then we have master mix
position for those
mixes which needed to be cooled then we
have a magnet here for separation
we have certain lids in there larger
reservoirs and some
tips over here which are used for the 96
row heads
sorry then this is the software
interface which is actually drastically
reduced just to the needs
of a user with not too many options on
it so the only thing
at the top level is that you can select
the general procedures which mean you
can select
for single step whether you like to move
the to the complete process
processing the library until it can be
run
on the sequencer at the end or you can
select
individual options and this is quite
helpful if you get samples which are
coming from
from another system if they are manual
samples you like to intercept in there
at a position and there you can continue
with this options you are selecting the
number of
samples you can decide your in how many
pools you like to do it
and this is uh off deck cycler
this is not the option we prefer and we
wouldn't advise
but some people just like like to have
it so it's a general
policy to have it in there so when the
deck is
filled with plastics and you have
decided which option you like to run
then you get a printout in case of a pdf
so you can also start you can feed it in
your database and your lymph system as
you wish which is actually showing
up the results from the guided laptop
set up so you see
the layout of the deck where you should
place your
tip boxes your plates and all the
material
then you get a position of the master
mixers if they are
in a block like here and
they are differently colored for the
different type of solutions you have to
place there
and in the middle you have a section
where actually you see the recipes for
the master mixers
we decided against the predispense and
automatically
set up of master mix for one reason
and this is cost effectiveness again
there are systems where you can do this
automatically and in principle you can
set it up also on the i7 here
but even if you spin down from the
master mix
boxes it's not as efficient to move all
the chemicals
out of the kits you get from the
companies
nab is quite generous and they call
their kids even automation friendly
and obviously there are because there's
a certain surplus in there which makes
it easier
but if you like to use a kit partially
once and
run it again and if you have automatic
setup of master mixes
then you're losing too much material and
so that's the reason why we are going
that way
and actually the people in our web like
this type of organization with that
printout they can go to the lab and see
immediately whether
they have to go to the cold room and get
new chemicals or whether
they can just take your local freezer
and get the material out of
there actually i mentioned in the first
slide that actually cost effectiveness
is one of the crucial points and i
mentioned it
in the setup of the master mixes we try
to minimize
and of course in the techniques in the
pipetting and the optimization of
of the program we minimize as much as
possible
but also for plastic materials we are
considering
different options how to pipe it with
possible reusing
how to optimize the steps at the end we
made
this table which required plastic
consumables
and actually on the left side
we made in grey the settings for
pre-pooling
process and the other one for the post
process
on top you see we did it once for 96
samples and one for 384 volt samples
and you can immediately see that
actually
during the individual sample process you
have
when we switch from 96 to 304
it's actually multiplying by the factor
of 4
as expected but if we are in the
predispense phase
master mix setting up and all this stuff
it's not growing
linear but only marginally and
in the level of pooling then even the
number of increasing is even
slower at that point it's very
very nicely actually as bjorn mentioned
in the beginning
to minimize costs on the chemical side
working with pools concentrating the
stuff
we really can mirror this attempt also
here
during the automation process and
optimizing it bjorn mentioned
several panels which are already
available
from neb so for tomato
maize and rice and we decided for this
test project
for the solar cap
so this is the result from the first 96
samples in one pool from the biomec i7
what is quite neat in there we have a
very steep
beginning of the library which optimize
optimizing the sequencing results as
it's really diminishing
useless empty sequence information
the yield is also quite high with 1.5
microgram
and the background is really low
so it's optimal entry point for
sequencing
this is the setup we used for
the sequencing on the illumina
instrument so we're taking
pad and 150 bases sequencing kit
we read the r1 with 20 bases
and we read from the other side with our
tool with 85 bases
actually the pool index we don't need
in the setup for for this testing if
you're going with 384 well
then of course we need the pool
information
yep these are the results from the
illumina sequencer
itself so the values
which were taking as optimal so above
who's 30 is 97 so as we would expect it
uh the other point is uh they're always
nicely high aligned so no diminishing
during the whole number of cycles this
is the normal base distribution in the
beginning of the read you see this
fluctuation
at the end it's quite stable i think
what's done more telling is than
at the end of results from the
bioinformatical analysis
so at first we are interested in past
filter reads
everything is above 150 000 reads so
everything is quite neat
then we are looking for coverage and
everything is above 50. so
substantially above it and actually we
get a green light
from direct genomics that actually
they're quite happy with this results
then we are looking for the general
sequencing matrix and
there we see again mapping on target is
about
94 quite equally about all of the
samples
and uniformity is above 97.5
and that's all what we like to see at
that point
i like to summarize our presentation the
following way
we could show that we achieve a complete
work away automation process
of the next genotyping solution
on the biomag i7 we show that you can
scale
from 96 even to 384 maybe more
we minimize the use of consumable
with respect to chemistry and also
plastic consumables
we produce the data which are equivalent
to the data which can be achieved
by a manual operator and
we can at the end even show that this
prototype is
able to be the basis for ultra high
throughput processing
in this genotyping field and i think
this is
very crucial for the future
i'd like to invite you just with the
last statement and saying
if you like to see the instrument live
and if you like to have
more information how we are doing the
things you are kindly invited to visit
us at
embl the project wouldn't be possible
with this large number of people
from all our company partners and
i think it was not only successful but
it was also
really nice and pleasant collaboration
thank you very much time for questions
thank you you're going to bjorn for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
okay our first question
is are you able to derive information on
the region
surrounding the marker for discovery of
haplotyping purposes
i will uh answer this for a misha yes
with the answer using the technology the
sequencing data provides information
within 75 best pairs
on either side of the targeted marker so
this data can be used for script
discovery efforts
but also can be used for haplotyping of
sets of markers
within the known proximity
great thank you have you tested the
technology on plant dna derived
extracted using different protocols
that is also correct the navnex direct
genotyping solution
has been tested on dna extracted using
also for example vtep buffer
as well as column purified dna the rich
spectacular technology produces similar
results
across these different extraction
methods
now is there any data from the
technology available to analyze
uh this is also possible um so we have
generated data sets for our tomato mates
and rice panels
that are available for downloading from
secure site
so in this case please reach out to neon
powerlabs
to get access to these panel data
okay now this audience member wants to
know what is a dart
that as i introduce it a little bit
during my presentation
is a system which is actually doing
sample tracking so actually
it's somehow a little limp system
which is dealing with sample information
so it can map it if the samples are
coming
on the system so then you can also feed
the information
of the sample into it which means
the volume whether it's a sample which
has to be
processed into a specific manner so
concentration
so you can have concentration adaptions
if necessary
and you can bind all the additional
information which are
gathered during the process to it so
when has it been processed so if you
have to document the whole thing in a
gmp
manner then you get all the information
out of it
together with the information the
protocol versioning of the protocol
who has started the protocol when was it
finished
is there any delay worked or something
wrong
and you can bind it together with
external data so you have interfaces
with sql and limb system and this makes
it really really powerful
actually we like it
oh that's great thank you okay we have
time for a few more questions
so this question says why did you choose
a biomec
i7
i don't know whether i like like to say
this as a as it is a sponsored event
but we are scientifically driven and
independently and uh
it's a design which is let's call it
like a tank
so depending on all the comparisons we
have made
to other providers it's a stable system
it competes it can deal with so many
exceptions
which you can feed into the system and
it's tolerating a lot of
external events like i mentioned so
plastic tolerances and all the things we
haven't seen this with
other providers in a way then it's
endurance so we're operating the
comparable systems already for quite a
while
and the other point is it's also related
a little bit
to the company itself and which means
it's the support it's the availability
during development phase
and that's uh also support afterwards
and we see the development of of the la
over the last years which are actually
resulting
in the i7 which makes it a quite mature
product that's to the history of the
instrument
and the other is it has a very large
deck
and the flexibility to introduce other
components
to have interfaces and to have
space to extend it to other systems i
think these are the main key components
which
drive our decision
great thank you okay and our last
question is
how about scalability to uh t
with the i7v prototype
the application and we could show that
we can cover
from mid throughput to high throughput
on that
machine quite officially if you like
to scale up even higher then we are
coming
to limit which is actually caused by the
technology
itself by this type of pipetting this is
not
dependent on the instrument on the
biomec i7
this is the general limit of technology
so
let's assume we can even do a down
scaling by factor of four
on a system which is already quite
efficient to do this
but in the next step how to imagine if
you like to do
millions of samples a day a year then
you can buy a multitude of
uh robots but you're still not reaching
the point the question is
what would be the next step of
technology to achieve this
and i think what is really good at that
point
is uh ultrasonic driven
dispensing and pipetting because there
you can reduce
the volumes even more drastically
and you're quite fast in doing this
so this would be quite neat interfacing
between an i7
and ultra high throughput ultrasonic
dispensing
and they can achieve really the very
high
sample throughput numbers
thank you again jurgen and bjorn do you
have any final comments for our audience
before we go
i'd like to thank you all that you
actually joined us
and i'd like to invite you if you have
further question
you can contact me by email
and if you like to visit us at amble i'd
just like to invite you to
i also say thank you on the other friend
labs and once again
uh thanking laproots and beckman culture
life sciences
for organizing this webinar it was a
great time
with you here and presenting our
new application with the team
thank you and before we go i'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their questions
any questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank jurgen
and bjorn for their time today
and their important research we would
also like to thank
labyrinths and our sponsor beckman
culture life sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye